สวัสดีค่ะครูฟ้าสวัสดีค่ะครูหญิงสวัสดี
ค่ะนักเรียนสวัสดีค่ะนักเรียนครูฟ้าวัน
นี้วันอะไรคะวันนี้วันจันทร์ค่ะค่ะวันที่
เท่าไหร่คะวันที่ 20 เอ้าไม่ใช่ 21 เนาะ
เดือนอะไรคะเดือน
กุมภาพันธ์ปีพ.ศอะไรคะปีพ.ศ
256  6 ค่ะปีค.ศอะไรคะปีค.ศ
2023 ค่ะค่ะเมื่อวานนี้วันอะไรคะเมื่อ
วานนี้วัน
อาทิตย์ค่ะวันที่เท่าไหร่คะวันที่ 19 อื
เดือนอะไรคะเดือนกุมภาพันธ์
ปีพ.ศอะไรคะปีพ.ศ
2566 ปีค.ศอะไรคะปีค.ศ
2023 ค่ะค่ะพรุ่งนี้วันอะไรคะพรุ่งนี้
วัน
อังคารวันที่เท่าไหร่คะวันที่
21 เดือนอะไรคะเดือน
กุมภาพันธ์ปีพ.ศอะไรคะปีพ.ศ
2566 ปีค.ศอะไรคะปีค.ศ
2023 ค่ะค่ะตอนนี้กี่โมงคะครูฟ้าตอนนี้
เวลา 10:00 น 10 นกี่นาที 105 นค่ะค่ะ 105
นก็เป็นเวลากลางวันเนาะอือกล่าว่าครูฟ้า
สบายดีนะคะครูฟ้าสบายดีค่ะครู
หญิงเมื่อวานเนี่ยเป็นวันอาทิตย์ใช่มยคะ
เมื่อวานนี้เนี่ยเป็นวัน
อาทิตย์ที่ 19 ใช่มยเมื่อวานนี้อ่าวัน
อาทิตย์เนี่ยครูหญิงกับครูฟ้าก็ไม่ต้องทำ
งานไม่ต้องสอนภาษา
ไทยอยู่บ้าน
กินแล้วก็นอนแล้วก็ดูซีรีส์แล้วก็กินแล้ว
ก็นอนใช่ไหมวัน
อาทิตย์สบายจังเลยครูหญิงเอ้าก็วันหยุดไง
ไม่ต้องทำ
งานครูฟ้าใช่มั้ยครูฟ้ากับครูหญิงเนี่ย
เหมือนกันนะคะเวลาวันหยุดอย่างเงี้ยวัน
อาทิตย์หรือว่าวันเสาร์ไม่ทำงานเนี่ยเรา
ก็จะหยุอยู่บ้านอยู่บ้านอยู่บ้านอยู่บ้าน
อยู่บ้านอยู่บ้านเยอะจังอยู่บ้านไงแต่ว่า
บางคนเคไม่ได้อยู่บ้านเหมือนครูหญิงกับ
ครูฟ้านะเอ้าแล้วบางคนเขอยู่ที่ไหนคะเ้า
เค้าก็ออกไปข้างนอกไงวันหยุดเนี่ยวัน
เสาร์วันอาทิตย์เ้าก็ออกไปข้างนอกบ้านอาจ
จะ
ไปอะไรนะพารากอนหรออือืพารากอนเป็น shing
Center นะคะนักเรียนอื
ไปใช่แต่ว่าก็ไม่ได้ไปช้อปปิ้งอย่างเดียว
นะเออแล้วไปทำอะไรล่ะคะที่พารากอนเนี่ย
นอกจากช้อปปิ้งเอ้าก็รอบๆพารากอนเนี่ยนะ
คะแต่ไม่ใช่ตอนกลางวันนะตอนกลางวันเนี่ย
ธรรมดาต้องเป็นตอนกลางคืนรอบๆพารากอนนี่
ก็จะมีไฟไฟไๆ
นี่คือไฟเหรอคะสีเหลืองๆเนี่ยอะไร
คะเอ้าที่นี่ไงเค้าก็จะมีแบบเป็น
ไฟสวย
ๆแล้วก็มีผู้
ชายผู้หญิงแล้วก็จะมีไฟตรงนี้จะมี
ไฟแล้วก็เป็นไฟนะคะนักเรียนไฟสวยๆแล้วก็
มีแบบนานาง
ฟ้าอย่างเงี้ยแล้วก็ไปนางฟ้าอยู่ใน
พารากอนใช่แต่ไม่ใช่นางฟ้าจริงๆนะนัก
เรียนเป็นไฟเป็นไฟเป็นไฟไๆไๆเป็นไฟเหมือน
อย่างเงี้นะนัก
เรียนเไฟใช่มยไฟอ่าแต่เป็นไฟที่อยู่ที่
นี่นะคะสวยๆคนไทยเนี่ยก็ไปถ่าย
รูปอืคนไทยเนี่ยชอบไปถ่ายรูปที่ไฟสวยๆหรอ
คะอ่ะถ้าเป็นกลางคืนเนี่ยเป็นกลางคืน
เนี่ยนะคะก็ชอบไปถ่ายรูปที่ไฟสวยๆแต่ถ้า
เป็นกลางวันล่ะกลางวันเนี่ยไฟเนี่ยไม่สวย
ครูฟ้าคิดว่ากลางวันเนี่ยคนไทยเนี่ยชอบไป
ถ่ายรูปที่ไหนอืครูฟ้ารู้มั้ยติ๊กตอกติ๊ก
ตอกติ๊กต
ตอกปคิด
ว่าคนไทยเนี่ยก็จะไปพารากอนค่ะเอ้าไป
พารากอนอีกเหรอคะชอบ
พารากอนพารากอนนะคะค่ะเมย G ค่ะพารากอน G
เหรอคะค่ะคุณนุไปพารากอนมาไม่ใช่หรอคะครู
ฟ้าลืมแล้วคนไทยก็จะ
ไปที่ไหนคะ
อันนี้อะไรคะครู
ฟ้าอ๋อห้องน้ำใช่ค่ะครูหญิงคนไทยก็จะไป
ห้องน้ำนะคะแล้วก็ตรงนี้ผู้
หญิงทำอะไรคะถ่าย
รูปถ่ายรูปในห้องน้ำเนี่ยนะถ่ายรูปอะไร
ถ่ายรูปกับอะไรในห้องน้ำก็ถ่ายรูปกับ
กระจกค่ะนี่
เลยกระจก
อืเหมือนเซลฟี่เซลฟี่อ่ะเหรอใช่ค่ะเซลฟี่
ในห้องน้ำนะคะหรือกระจกอันนี้ก็ได้เนี่ย
กระจกกระจกอืแล้วก็เซลฟี่ในห้องครูฟครู
ฟ้าเคยเซลฟี่กับกระจกมยเคยถ่ายรูปรูปคู่
กับกระจกมยคะมีมยรูปครูฟ้ากับกระจกครูฟ้า
เคยถ่ายนะคะเดี๋ยวโอครูหญิงก็เคยนะแต่ว่า
ไม่ใช่ห้องน้ำอ่ะเป็นกระจกแบบนี้แหละใช่
แต่เป็นกระจกที่ออฟฟิศูฟ้าถ่ายรูปกับ
กระจกเหมยบ้านเพื่อนค่ะอืไปบ้านเพื่อน
แล้วก็ถ่ายรูปนะคะเซลฟี่มาครูฟ้าชอบถ่าย
รูปกับกระจกมย
ไม่ค่อยขายตัวเอง
อ่ะไม่หรอแต่กูหญิงคิดว่าถ้าครูฟ้าจะถ่าย
รูปกับอะไรครูฟ้าจะถ่ายกับกระจกเพราะว่า
นั่นสิโทรศัพท์มันบังหน้าครูฟ้าไงเออ
ใช่คใช่่สับังอืเออเก็ถ่ายรูปกับกระจก
อยู่นะบางครั้งนะคะอือืใช่ค่ะเออใช่ค่ะ
ครูหญิงก็เคยเห็นอือืคนไทยชอบถ่ายรูปใน
ห้องน้ำนะคะไม่รู้ทำไมนะนักเรียนแต่คนไทย
เนี่ยไปห้องน้ำใช่มยไปห้องน้ำแล้วก็ไยอื
ใช่่สมมุติว่านักเรียนใช่มั้ยนักเรียน
เนี่ยเป็นนักเรียนผู้ชายอืแล้วนักเรียน
เนี่ย
อ่ะแป๊บนึงนะคะถ้านักเรียนเนี่ยเป็นนัก
เรียนผู้ชายใช่มยเป็นผู้ชายแล้วนักเรียน
มีแฟนแฟนนักเรียนเนี่ยเป็นผู้หญิงไทยแล้ว
แฟนบอกเออเดี๋ยวไปห้องน้ำใช่มั้ยไปห้อง
น้ำห้องน้ำเนี่ยนักเรียนก็คิดว่าแฟนไป
ห้องน้ำแล้วก็นักเรียนก็รอใช่มั้ยรอๆเอ 5
นาที 10 นาทีทำไมแฟนไปห้องน้ำนานจังอมี
คิวหรอมีคิวคิวเยอะอาจจะไม่ใช่ก็ได้นะอาจ
จะไปถ่ายรูปอยู่ในห้องน้ำเพว่าห้องน้ำสวย
ก็มีไงบางที่เนี่ยห้องน้ำสวยแล้วก็ไฟสวย
ใช่มยอืๆ
ๆบางทีเนี่ยทุกอย่างสวยนะคะไฟในห้องน้ำ
สวยไฟในห้องน้ำเนี่ยมันสวยนะคะใช่แต่ถ้า
ไม่ใช่ห้องน้ำครูหญิงคิดว่ามีอีกอย่างนึง
ที่คนไทยโดยเฉพาะตั้งแต่ักช่วง 2  0  2  1
2  0  2  2 เนี่ยคนไทยชอบไปถ่ายรูปด้วย
มากๆเหมือนกันแต่อาจจะเป็นผู้หญิงนะคะนัก
เรียนส่วนใหญ่เนี่ยอาจจะ
90% ผู้หญิงไม่ค่อยเป็นผู้
ชายผู้ชายไม่ค่อยถ่ายรูปในห้องน้ำมใช่ค่ะ
ใช่ค่ะเออแล้วก็อีกอย่างนึงที่ผู้หญิงชอบ
ไปถ่ายรูปเนี่ย
ก็คิดว่าคิดว่าส่วนใหญ่ผู้หญิงเนี่ยชอบ
ถ่ายรูปตัว
เองอืส่วนผู้ชายเนี่ยเป็นตากล้องใช่มั้ย
ผู้ชายอาจจะมีอาจจะมีกล้องก็ได้นะอืจะมี
เนี่ยกล้องถ่ายรูปหรือว่าใช้โทรศัพท์นี่
แหละใช่มผู้ชายเนี่ยก็เป็นคนถ่ายให้อื
อก็มีนี่ผู้หญิงก็จะวาดพยายามวาดให้เป็น
เหมือนครูฟ้านะคะที่นี่ก็จะมีโทรศัพท์ใช่
มั้ยอ่า
อใช่แล้วก็ตรงนี้ก็จะเป็นผู้
หญิงผู้หญิงก็จะยืนอยู่ผู้ชายเนี่ยเป็นตา
กล้องใช่มั้ยคะผู้หญิงเนี่ยเป็นเหมือนนาง
แบบมยเหมือนซุปเปอร์โมเดล
โพสใช่ก็แฟนกันไง
ออผู้หญิงก็ชอบถ่ายรูปแลถ้าผู้ชายเนี่ย
ถ่ายรูปเก่งๆโอ้โหโชคดีนะเรามีแฟนที่ถ่าย
รูปสวยดีมากอืใช่ค่ะครูหญิงเพื่อนครูฟ้า
ที่เป็นผู้ชายก็ถ่ายรูปนะคะส่วนใหญ่ผู้
ชายไม่ค่อยถ่ายรูปตัวเองใช่มยค่ะแต่ผู้
หญิงถ่ายรูปตัวเองใชอืใช่ค่ะแล้วก็ผู้
หญิงเนี่ยชอบถ่ายถ้าถ่ายกับกระจกใช่ไหมคะ
ก็จะเป็นการเซลฟี่เซลฟี่ก็คือถ่ายเองแต่
ถ้าไปในที่สวยๆอย่างพวกเค้าเรียกอะไรทุ่ง
ดอกไม้หรอที่มันจะมีแบบดอกไม้ดอกไม้ดอก
ไม้ดอกไม้ดอกไม้ตนี้ก็เป็นดอก
ไม้แล้วก็ตรงนี้ก็เป็นดอกไม้มีดอกไม้
เนี่ยดอก
ไม้ดอกไม้เยอะๆอ่ะค่ะมีดอกไม้ดอกไม้ดอก
ไม้แล้วเราเราก็ยืนตรงนี้ใช่มยแล้วแฟน
เนี่ยก็ถ่ายรูปให้เราครูหญิงว่าตอนนี้คน
ก็ชอบถ่ายรูปกับดอกไม้นะอืทำไมคนถึงชอบ
ถ่ายรูปกับดอกไม้ล่ะครูหญิงมันต้องเครู
ฟ้าดอกไม้เนี่ยมันสวยไงคะแต่ต้องมีคิด
ด้วยนะครูหญิงเคยดูดูวีีดีโอใน YouTube
เวลาผู้หญิงเนี่ยเค้าคิดจะไปถ่ายรูปถ่าย
รูปกับดอกไม้เนี่ยเขาต้องคิดนะคะว่าดอก
ไม้ถ้าดอกไม้เนี่ยสี
ชมพู
อืเราต้องใส่เสื้อสีอะไร
สวยดอกไม้ใส่เสื้อสีอะไรสวยะสีเหลืองใช่
ค่ะถามครูหญิงถามครูฟ้าไม่เข้าใจนะคะนัก
เรียนเพราะว่าเรา 2 คนไม่ถ่ายรูปกับดอก
ไม้ก็ถ่ายนะแต่ไม่คิดขนาดนั้นนะคะ
อืมครูฟ้าเคยไปถ่ายรูปกับดอกไม้มั้ยอืครู
ฟ้าไม่เคยถ่ายรูปกับดอกไม้
ค่ะอย่างเงี้ยค่ะนักเรียนแต่อนี้เค้าเป็น
ซุปเปอร์สตาร์ไทยนะคะนักเรียนก็สวยอ่ะ
เนาะ
อื้อหือไนหรือว่าแบบ
นี้เนี่ยอย่างงี้เห็นมั้ยเนี่ยมีทุ่งใช่
มั้ยมีดอกไม้มีใบไม้สวยๆเห็นมั้ยดอกไม้สี
แดงก็ต้องใส่ชุดสีอะไรจะสวยอืีนี้คนไทย
ต้องคิดนะคะนักเรียนอ่ะหรือว่าครูฟ้าาจะ
ถ่ายรูปกับดอกไม้แบบนี้มั้ยแบบลิซ่าเหรอ
คะใช่แต่ครูฟ้าไม่เคยใช่มั้ยคะไม่เคยถ่าย
รูปกับดอกไม้ครูหญิงเคยนะเคยครูหญิงเคย
เห็น
ดอกไม้แล้วก็มันสวยดีนะคะก็เลยถ่ายแต่คิด
ว่าน่าจะหาไม่เจอนะคะนักเรียนอุยผู้หญิง
เคยถ่ายรูปกับดอก
ไม้ใช่คุหญิงเคยถ่ายนี่นี่ไง
อุ๊ยโอ้ยไม่อยากให้ดูเยอะๆเลยอ่ะไม่สวย
เนี่ยค่ะนักเรียนเห็นมั้ยโอผู้หญิงโอเคนะ
เนี่ยดอกไม้อือ
หก็เคยถ่ายรูปกับดอกไม้แต่ครูหญิงเนี่ย
ไม่ได้ชอบถ่ายรูปกับดอกไม้มากที่สุดเ้า
แล้วผู้หญิงชอบถ่ายรูปกับอะไรมากที่สุด
ล่ะอผู้หญิงคิดว่านักเรียนเนี่ยเดาได้ไม่
ยากเลยนะคะเมื่อก่อนนะเมื่อก่อนสักประมาณ
ปี
2  2  2  0  1  3 เนี่ยก็ประมาณ
10 ปีที่แล้วใช่ไหมยคะครูหญิงเนี่ยชอบ
ถ่ายรูปแล้วก็โพสต์ลงโซเชียลมีเดีย
อ่า Facebook เนาะเมื่อก่อน Facebook ใช่
มั้ยคะแล้วก็ชอบถ่ายรูปแต่ไม่ใช่ถ่ายรูป
ครูหญิงกับดอกไม้หรือว่ารูปครูหญิงกับ
กระจกเนี่ยไม่ค่อยค่ะเ้า Facebook ครู
หญิงเนี่ย 99%
ก็
คืออาหารผู้หญิงชอบถ่ายรูปกับอาหารหรอใช่
ค่ะผู้หญิงชอบมีอาหารถืออาหารสมมุติว่า
ครูครูหญิงบอกครูฟ้าครูฟ้าครูหญิงก็ยกเอา
โทรศัพท์ครูหญิงเนี่ยให้ครูฟ้าใช่มั้ย
แล้วก็ครูฟ้าถ่ายรูปถ่ายรูปให้ครูหญิง
หน่อยถ่ายรูปให้ครูหญิงครูหญิงจะถ่ายรูป
อะไรนี่ไงพิซซ่าอ่ะครูหญิงก็จะถือ
พิซซ่าแล้วเก็ถ่ายใช่พิซซ่าอย่างเดียวได้
มั้ยไม่ใช่ต้องมีพิซซ่าพิซซ่าแล้วก็หน้า
ครูหญิงด้วย
อืโูหต้องเราต้องแอคชั่นไง
เดี๋ยวอย่างงี้ไงเออครูฟ้าไม่ถ่ายรูปกับ
อาหาร
หรอ
nor ไม่นะคะคทำไมถ่ายรูปเพราะว่าครูฟ้า
ถ่ายรูปอาหารเท่านั้นค่ะย
อ๋อครูฟ้านี่ไงนี่ไงนี่ไงเห็นมั้ยทำ
โทรศัพท์ตกนะคะอุ้ยครูหญิงกับพิซซ่านะคะ
นัก
เรียนอันนี้ถ่ายเองเห็นมยเซลฟี่โทรศัพท์
โอเคมั้ยโอครูพ่อทำโทรศัพท์ตกเมื่อกีู้
ฟ้าถ่ายรูปอาหารอ๋อแต่ครูฟ้าเนี่ยไม่ถ่าย
รูปคู่กับอาหารก็คือไม่ใช่มีอาหารแล้วก็
ครูฟ้าเนี่ยไม่อ่าครูฟ้าถ่ายกับถ่ายอาหาร
เลยอาหารเท่านั้นนะคะอาหาร
อือะไรอย่างเงี้ยทำไมทำไมไม่มีครูฟ้าล่ะ
อาหารอือุ๊ยเซี่เหรอคะอ่ะครูฟ้า
เนี่ยกับดอกไม้ครูฟ้าก็ไม่ถ่ายรูปด้วยกับ
ออาหารครูฟ้าก็ไม่ถ่ายรูปด้วยถ้าครูฟ้า
แล้วครูฟ้าชอบถ่ายรูปกับอะไร
อ่ะถ้าถ่ายรูปอ่ะนะอาจจะไม่ได้แบบมากๆ
เพราะว่าครูฟ้าเนี่ยไม่ชอบครูฟ้าไม่ชอบ
ถ่ายรูปตัวเองใช่มั้ยคะถ่ายรูปครูฟ้า
เนี่ยไม่ค่อยแต่ถ้าสมมุติว่าครูฟ้าจะถ่าย
รูปครูฟ้าชอบถ่ายรูปคู่กับอะไรถ่ายรูปกับ
อะไรคู่กับที่ไม่ใช่เพื่อนนะที่ไม่ใช่
เพื่อนเป็นของสิแบบดอกไม้อย่างเงี้ยบางคน
ก็ถ่ายกับกระจกใช่มยบางคนถ่ายกับอาหารบาง
คนถ่ายกับ
รถอ่าบางคนถ่ายกับกาแฟ starbuck ใช่มยือ
แก้วกาแฟแล้วก็ถ่ายอย่าเงี้ยครูฟ้าล่ะู้
หญิงคิดว่าครูฟ้าถ่ายรูปกับแมว
แมวก็ได้ค่ะเออใช่มย
อืเพครูฟ้าเนี่ยมี
แมวนี่แมวใช่มั้ยคะแล้วก็อนี้ครูฟ้าอื
อือืแมวอยู่บนหัวครูฟ้านะคะอือ
อืครูฟ้าถือแมวอย่างงี้เหรอคะนี่ไงครูฟ้า
ก็ถ่ายรูปกับแมวอืมอแมวนะคะน่ารักนะคะอืเ
ก็รักแมวก็เลยชอบถ่ายรูปคู่กับแมวไงใช่
คือถ้านักเรียนเนี่ยนักเรียนรักหมานัก
เรียนก็อาจจะถ่ายรูปคู่กับหมาใช่มั้ยถ่าย
รูปคู่กับหมาก็อาจจะอุ้มใช่มั้ยอุ้มหมา
แล้วก็ถ่ายรูป
อืแต่ว่าอย่างครูหญิงเนี่ยไม่มีแมวไม่มี
หมาครูหญิงก็อาจจะถ่ายรูปกับแมวครูฟ้าก็
ได้อือืใช่มเดินรูแมวูฟ้าหรอใช่ค่ะหรือ
คิดว่ามีอีกอย่างนึงที่ครูหญิงคิดว่าตอน
นี้หลายๆคนก็อาจจะคือเมื่อก่อนเราอาจจะ
รู้สึกแบบเอ๊ทำไมแต่ว่าตอนนี้เนี่ยก็โอเค
นะอย่างเช่นอ่ะก็คือสมมุติอันนี้มันมี
ป้ายใช่มั้ยคะอาจจะเป็นป้ายอะไรดีล่ะอิ่ม
สมมุติชานลแล้วกันเจนนี่ blackpink อย่าง
เงี้ยแล้วก็มีเจนนี่ใช่มยเป็น
พรีเซ็นเตอร์แล้วก็ครูหญิงก็ยืนที่นี่
แล้วก็แอคชั่นแล้วครูฟ้าก็ถ่ายรูปให้ไง
ถ่ายรูปคู่กับพวกป้ายเนี่ยอืป้ายสวยๆไงอื
ผู้หญิงชอบถ่ายรูปป้ายหรอเฮ้ยครูฟ้าบาง
อันมันสวย
นะจริงหรอคือป้ายบางป้ายเนี่ยออนี่ๆไงใช่
มั้หรือว่าถ้าครูฟ้าชอบซุปเปอร์สตาร์
เกาหลีอือก็ถ่ายแบบนี้นะคะอันนี้ใครก็ไม่
รู้นะคะุหญิงไม่รู้จักนี่ไงอย่างเงี้ยอัน
นี้
เอ่อเห็นมเนี่ยมีป้ายใช่มยเป็นป้ายโฆษณา
แล้วเราก็ยืนถ่ายรูปตอนนี้เถ่ายรูปกับตัว
เองนะคะอืเออ
โหอ้าหรือว่าอย่างงี้เห็นมั้ยตลาดพลูตลาด
พลูใช่มั้ยตอนเนี้ยเขาก็ชอบนะถ่ายรูปคู่
กับป้ายต่างๆมันก็ดู
แบบสวยยมั้งมันดูเท่เหรอคะคุณหญิงก็ไม่
รู้เหมือนกันนะคะแต่ว่าเป็นสิ่งที่แบบิิอ
มยเออนะคะเละค่ะแล้วนักเรียนล่ะคะนัก
เรียนชอบถ่ายรูปกับอะไรก็คอมเมนต์บอกเรา
ได้นะคะส่วนวีดีโอนี้เนี่ยครูหญิงกับครู
ฟ้าก็ไปก่อนนะคะแล้วเดี๋ยวเรามาเจอกัน
ใหม่วีดีโอหน้าสวัสดีค่ะ